j'envie l'eau parlons de vacances mais
en les étudiant sous un aspect un peu
particulier les gens sont de plus en
plus nombreux à partir en vacances à se
ruer sur les vacances dirais-je ceux là
même dont les revenus sont le plus
grignotées par l'inflation
ceux là mêmes qui prennent le plus de se
trouver au chômage en france comme
ailleurs en europe les cadres des
employés les ouvriers consacrent une
part croissante de leur budget à leurs
vacances il y a là un paradoxe tout au
moins apparent quelle est leur véritable
motivation se distille quelque chose
comme la crise connaît pas ou bien
s'agit-il d'une fuite en avant
une enquête de juin marque il use et
pire moscovitch 10 heures chaque jour
dans les encombrements c'est l'univers
d'alain goldschmidt pour lui les
vacances ne sont pas un luxe superflu
on a on a besoin d'avoir des vacances et
c'est pas devenu un c'est pas un droit
si vous voulez mais c'est un besoin
l'organisme s'en ressent je ne souhaite
qu'une chose c'est
me dire monde l'année prochaine ce soir
encore des vacances vous tuera au même
endroit où sur ailleurs ailleurs un
ailleurs n'importe où à l'abri du
ras-le-bol
un petit coin de paradis sous un brin de
parasol au diable l'inflation la
circulation les précipitations on veut
tout oublier à tout prix profession
ambulanciers infirmiers employés de
mairie il y a dix ans il ne paraît
qu'une seule fois en vacances cet été
après la tunisie ils iront à golfe juan
nous savions les enfants bazaille mon
mari était seul à travailler maintenant
je travaille et en plus on avait la
maison à payer enfin on voulait une
voiture on voulait plusieurs choses que
maintenant on peut se permettre de faire
mais beaucoup de ceux qui flânent dans
les soupes de djerba n'ont pas vraiment
les moyens on regarde mais on n'achète
pas pour débourser les 16 cents ou 2000
francs du forfait une semaine paris
paris tout compris
il a fallu être acrobat est impossible
d'aller plus loin
mon budget je vais vraiment me conformer
ne me ferai pas cette assertion en
vacances mais j'essaie quand même de
faire au coup par coup est parti le plus
souvent possible
je pense que la vie parisienne est très
tendu très contraignante que je crois
que c'est un choix à faire
je préfère faire ce choix de partir
assez souvent plutôt que d'avoir une
résidence secondaire ou une voiture de
beaucoup plus grand que celle que j'ai
j'essaie de m'organiser et j'ai
téléphoné d'économies pendant un certain
temps pour pouvoir partir une semaine en
vacances
ah non je vais pas supprimer les
vacances je m'arroge et je sais pas
comment mais je partirai je partirai à
tout prix tu partiras à crédit après le
bronzage le déluge on se débrouillera le
bout du monde sans joindre les deux
bouts on économisera sur le reste
les experts parlent le comportement
économique incohérent pourtant partout
en europe et plus récemment en france
cadres employés ouvriers préfère jouer
la carte du ouvrira bien coincé entre
les mauvais souvenirs de 74 et les
incertitudes de l'avenir ou choisi
l'abondance factice la fuite en avant
période d' équilibre économique
on anticipe ses achats en période de
crise on vit la fête
or la fête ce sont les vacances les
français fuient un système
il fut un mode de consommation ils ne
prêtent plus à leur système économique
c'est un phénomène nouveau un phénomène
que je pourrai eux analysé de la manière
suivante c'est peut-être leur à une
société qui a besoin d'encore d'un
équilibre
oui
hors de tout